yeah this is pretty cool
like a lot of a lot of legends here a
couple of goats
can you have more than one goat not sure
this is probably like the happiest that
i've seen kasparov
yeah usually he's like he's very serious
if goat is a lifetime title then yeah
there are several of them
in st louis um they have like a goat
petting zoo
[Music]
you see i might actually have photos
from it
this was this is me
attempting to feed a goat it's hard to
like feed a goat and pose for the camera
anyway let's go back let's play some
more chess
random challenge oh dear
i'm being forced to play a fried liver
opponent so wow
so this is a very famous position
uh pretty sure the only move here is
knight c7
idea i have to hold on for dear life
i'm actually not sure
the theoretical standing of this line i
assume it's it's
probably close to winning for white
even though like if you turn on the
engine it will say
maybe slightly better for black
i'll play c6
i'm scared my opponent might have
preparation here too
these are the only two moves i know
rookie one is terrifying so i'm thinking
just run the king
because i i can't i can't live on the e
file
thanks for subbing serious lizness
something something with not enough
vowels
something with prime and r ex trella
also subbing with prime thanks so much
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if chat
knows more about this position than me
okay d3 seems like kind of a timid move
but there's a funny thread of is there a
threat of taking maybe not
play bishop e6
it's just such an awkward position
maybe i can play there's a bishop g5
coming too
i mean h16 is really slow also this is
this is blitz so i probably have to move
more quickly
um
i'll play h6
because i i assume this was like the
biggest threat
there's some bonus of preparing g5
bishop g7 or cafe
yeah i'm sure there's been like engine
games or just
engines spending a lot of time in
these lines
because engines are very materialistic
where
remember remember so many years ago like
studying this line
which it says black's just like up a
piece
um but then the the deeper you dig the
more it realizes white's
doing quite well
[Music]
i don't know if we're following like any
sort of theory that's
kind of an annoying move
probably gonna have to allow this
play king c7 and then go for queen d6
okay if we can trade queens all i'll be
happy
and the king is um it's not getting
mated which is nice
hey f6 rules is subbing
for five months
just want the complete development
making sure this is under control
there's a line ooh
there's a few scary lines here
i'm pretty sure white's winning with
correct play but i don't want to say
anything
whoa it's kimmy gifting subs thanks
kimmy
gifting five subs to star up monkey
library
volley something something
your boy deep roy and smash factors
and give another shout out to kimmy
really appreciate that
kimmy lou 18. people should check her
out on twitch
okay time to focus yeah white still has
initiative
[Music]
okay what to do my eyes
this position just makes my eyes hurt
there's so many concerns
like the main concern is takes takes
bishop f4
which is terrifying rook d it doesn't
help
maybe g's no g16
g6 bishop g7 idea
let's try it i'm also defending oh
i think i just blundered
g6 was was not working at all
but okay we're both on time yeah it's a
really good move
oh opponent gave me more time my
opponent wants to beat me
fair and square and not flag me
the problem is i can't really do much
unless i can i'm gonna have to give away
my queen
yeah so this is the best
this is not good though wait what's
material
maybe it's not so bad i can take
that's so nice that point is so generous
i i get anxious when i fall below 10
minutes and then
anxiety goes away
okay
i'm just trying to calculate the best
course of action
i think a6 no a6 is no good let's take
and play king c6
idea bishop d6 i'm not going to be as
generous
and no extra time for my opponent
um no free rook for my opponent oh
wait what just happened ah oh my pawn
i just do opened up the source code
okay
oh this is really bad
and bishop beautiful bishop
oh okay
somehow i won that i don't know how i
won
that was only 19 moves oh that was kind
of a thematic game
opponent was so generous to me
was that karma that was the opposite of
karma 95 horatio for my sub gift oh
lovinator thanks sean
[Music]
yeah white played really well
overpower the bishop all white needs to
do is like
make some loot for the king any any pawn
move is winning
okay that was that was a mess
i freaked out also towards the end
because i did something with code
but maybe maybe it worked it works in my
favor kind of
analysis board
so i'm really curious what the engine
will say about this position
did you check out the chess variants
they ran alpha zero on i saw that it
would be more interesting than classical
chess in competitive play
yeah i saw danny ranch's video let's go
let's go oh yeah let's check sockfish
but first let's
guess i remember like probably a decade
ago
some fritz was saying minus one so okay
i'll guess minus one
oh okay computers got stronger
yeah so this line's probably refuted
[Music]
um oh if i could i yeah maybe i can show
i'm sure there's some people
who maybe don't know about this line but
this line comes from a fried liver
which starts as a two nights defense
after knight g5
um it's very common at like beginner
play but also
like you'll sometimes see this at gm
level
um d5 takes now the main line here is
knight
a5 and then there's some long theory
um but the the trap emerges after this
this is this and then the only way
for black to defend the knight is to
develop the king
which brought us to
yeah to this position
[Music]
so curious any master level games
oh i thought knight b4 runs into a3 but
maybe there's some line i don't know
about
yeah i feel like i saw some messages in
the chat about this move
this is just not a variation i really
studied so much
from from either color but it's
something that every
every serious player has seen at some
point
wait why not okay a3 doesn't work here
or does it
a3 knight c2 king d1 takes
ah king d6
allows black to survive
yeah d4 is um
i don't know if i mentioned this but um
yeah d3 is a little bit slow
and d4 is a lot more in the spirit of
the lineup
sensei hope you're well d
arigato kamichiwa